[Music]
here we have the representations of the
life cycle of two organisms one picture
depicts the life cycle of a butterfly
while the other shows the development
stages of a human have you ever wondered
how does this little caterpillar turn
into a butterfly or even how does such a
small baby turn into an adult
butterflies go through some spectacular
lifecycle transformations that is from a
lowly worm into a glorious creature that
floats on the breeze on similar lines
humans also follow a developmental
pattern they go through a series of
developmental stages from the time of
birth to the time they mature into an
adult and these transformations are
mainly possible all thanks to the
process of cell cycle and cell division
we all know that each multicellular
organism begins life in the form of a
single cell so how does a single cell
get transformed into a large organism to
comprehend this let's understand the
concept of a cell cycle and cell
division let's begin with that
definitions cell cycle is a series of
well orchestrated steps including cell
growth duplication of genetic material
and cell division usually resulting in
two identical cells in other words a
cell passes through various steps in
order to grow copy its DNA and finally
split into either two or four new cells
this is cell cycle and what exactly is
cell division as the name suggests cell
division is the process in which a
single parent cell divides into either
two identical cells or four cells each
with half the number of chromosomes so
can we say that the process of cell
division is a part of the cell cycle
that's right that's how it is now tell
me one thing do all the cell's divide in
the same way
think about it the answer is a definite
no right every cell in our body has a
different tendency to grow and divide to
be precise
some cells divide throughout their
lifetime while others do not divide once
formed for example our skin cells have a
high turnover rate due to constant wear
and tear and divide very frequently on
the other hand our nerve cells do not
divide once formed now getting back to
the cell cycle as the name suggests the
process occurs in phases or stages the
series of steps that repeat in cyclic
manner but for our convenience we
majorly divide a cell cycle into two
phases the first phase is called the
interphase and the next is the M phase
which represents either mitotic or
mitotic phase let's have a quick look at
these phases the interphase prepares the
cell for cell division hence it's also
called the preparatory phase in this
phase the cell grows and makes a copy of
its genetic material the DNA to be
precise on the other hand the M phase is
the dividing phase of the cell cycle it
carries out the task of actual cell
division after going through a series of
steps the self first divides the nucleus
into two sets followed by the division
of the cytoplasm this gives rise to two
identical daughter cells and this
process of cell division is called
mitosis similarly instead of once a
parent cell divides twice to give four
daughter cells each with half the amount
of genetic material compared to the
parent cells this type of division is
called meiosis the one useful in the
production of gametes now tell me one
thing will both the phases the
interphase and the M phase have the same
time duration or will one phase last
longer than the other if yes then which
phase will need more time just think
about it imagine we were to prepare a
meal
the actual time required to cook the
food is usually less compared to the
time we take for preparations that is
right from getting things from the store
to keeping things ready for cooking we
consume a lot of time pre-cooking the
sell isn't an exception for the most
crucial and challenging tasks like
division of nucleus followed by
cytoplasm the cell takes a lot of time
to prepare for these steps rather than
the actual divisions the interphase
lasts much longer compared to the M
phase you will be astonished to know
that the interphase occupies more than
90 percent of the total time required
for one cycle and only the remaining
less than 10% of the time is needed for
the M phase to get the new cells formed
so all the important functions like
growth duplication of genetic material
synthesis of newer compounds and
organelles all of these are carried out
in the interphase it is believed that
the cells take up approximately 24 hours
to complete one cycle however this
duration can vary from organism to
organism and from one cell type to the
other later at the end of the cycle the
new cells produced can start the exact
same process all over again that's the
reason why it's called a cycle as it
does not follow a linear pathway well
this was just an overview of the two
major phases of a cell cycle to know in
detail about each phase and the sub
stages in each phase do watch our
upcoming videos
[Music]